hi folks my name's Tamara chambers and
this is Tamara's never seen today I am
watching the crow so got this whole sad
like or over it obviously so that's
going to be very interesting and sadly
intriguing if that makes sense I'm very
interested in this film and I can't wait
so let's do it y'all so good right off
the bat right in the beginning I loved
the cop character he has some great
lines pop to always have those lines
that are like oh man that was such a dad
zinger line that no these are like
actually fun kind of funny but more just
like he's a good actors or he pulls them
off really well he's comforting Sara the
detective asks them a stupid question is
this the girl he's like no it's Amelia
Earhart so there's a scene that shows
you all of the bad guys of the movie and
they're destroying arcade games and this
really cool old arcade and that is by
far the worst part of the movie so far
and two people have died oh yeah Shelley
and Erica died we haven't seen it that's
what happens so it's been a year since
the deaths and I wrote down eric crawled
out of his grave and is walking around
composing himself and he's like this
gorgeous guy he seems to be emotionally
connected so far as the beginning of the
movie but seems to be a good actor the
movie itself is a sad story buzz it like
oh my god just knowing the whole time
that this guy that Brandon Lee dies
during production of the film at the
very end it's just like I was really sad
like I said like this sad intriguing but
sad layer to it dad who else had said
that before my the first is hot hot no
opinion up in the movie it's sad
great there's this whole like rape and
murder montage where they show you what
happened to Aaron tensions fiance
Shelley and it is one of the more
depressing montages that I've seen to
this theory and he goes you put on
makeup some a leather outfit new Texas
cash badass is also something that I do
every day on the daily Amir buddy
yeah you love that we do this every day
yeah yeah I'm sure you do
sure you loved it he loved it he loved
it he really does obvious identify was a
character at last
it's one thing right away kills murderer
rapist number one yeah you've got this
great line that he says and I loved it I
wrote it down who says they're all dead
they died a year ago the moment they
touched her they just don't know it yet
oh yes hell yeah that is some revenge
ass shit he saved Sara from a car
hitting her and she's like get off me
man whatever and shit she's like this
young little tough Punk who's had a lot
of hard heart ship
heart ship heartbreak rough time she's
like me and I wish it would stop raining
for once he's like can train all the
time she recognizes that cuz he had a
song that said that then he goes and
confronts Sara's mom like this badass
like mr. Rogers character he's like your
daughter's out on the street waiting for
you if she goes off and starts becoming
a better mom and then he shoots fun boy
who's rapist murderer number two in the
leg which is a plus they just killed him
killed
fun boy who's the second rapist murderer
just killed him with like shoppes of
drugs in the heart and he does his like
cool crow emblem calling card thing it's
awesome it reminds me of Pikmin from
fallout 4
who is he like uses the blood like
victims to paint art I so really love
the unlikely friendship between Eric and
a cop
Eric shows up at the cops house with a
cop like oh yeah totally cool come on in
Eric is like you shouldn't smoke
cigarettes
kill you it's really funny coming from
the undead I wrote down for an early 90s
movie that's like comic book based this
is weirdly written pretty well in a
convincing way that keeps me engaged
murder rapist kill number three is
definitely my fav the exploding car into
the river the fire crow masterful
masterful work then there's a beautiful
scene between Sarah and Eric he gives
her the engagement ring that was
shelling that was really sweet
she's not the greatest actress I'll say
but I do think that her character was
really written well and used well in the
story I really enjoyed the moment that
she was there Eric goes in to the main
bad guy layer and just kills them all
like you're all going to die and he's
looking for murder rapist number four to
finish out his quest it ends up that the
main bad guy his henchman and his weird
half-sister slash girlfriend is also
half sister slash girlfriend girl has
like the og over Tron list and it really
sloppy wouldn't get away with it in the
beauty world today but I kind of love it
kind of a kind of copying her a bit
right now good for her she went with a
bold choice didn't really pay off but
she's rock picked so then the main bad
guy and the henchman and the girlfriend
slash half-sister take Sarah to get Eric
to comes like a bait kind of thing
honestly though the way that Sarah runs
around these bad neighborhoods to wonder
she's not been taken for just gonna
throw that out there that's like a story
plot thing Eric goes to savor and his
powers are gone that was a little
unclear for me but he doesn't have his
powers anymore so the cop comes in to
help out and he has got to be filmed the
most helpful and well-written cops this
cop is she's on top of it he's well
acted he's well written and he's very
helpful and then I wrote fuck he gets
shot there's a huge fight between Eric
and the main bad guy and Eric ends up
killing him with memories of it's
honestly really cool and then it stops
raining he returns to his grave he sees
get to kiss Shelley surrogacy engagement
ring gorgeous it's sad there's a tribute
at the end to Brandon and then I was
just crying I cried at the end of this
comic book movie that was made in the
early 90s how was that possible I could
not tell also on the more technical side
I couldn't tell what scenes of the were
not Brandon so they did it really well
and in a tasteful way
I'm really glad they ended up finishing
this film I know that must have been
like a weird like moral gray ground just
like God do we did we finish this this
is more of a tribute if we finish it or
is it disrespectful if we finish it
where does this lie I loved it I thought
it was really good I thought it was
really well done I thought it was dark
and I had a really cool theme and vibe
and I thought really cool lessons were
learned and I loved it I loved it I
wrote just finished the crow Wow so glad
I watched it ya'll says those prediction
in and then I put a pigeon heads there
were no crows and a Black Hawk and says
you'll crave Goffe makeup and clothes
for at least a week afterwards yeah I
mean damn right after the movie I had to
literally go put on black and lipstick
you'll cry over the fact that Bruce
Lee's son Brandon Lee passed away in the
making of The Crow Plus the sequels are
bad by the way I won't be watching the
sequels I don't think um I don't imagine
that they could be anything close to
this I think part of the magic is that
not a good word to use the part of the
intrigue of this is that Brandon Lee was
so good it was his first film ever right
um he was so good in this he acted it
well he just looks the part why would
you make another no I guess it did well
some money but why you'll think he's
kind of sexy in a creepy Joker II way
you will find the soundtrack and never
stop listening to it because it's
amazing it was so good the music was so
good in a way that doesn't take you out
of it you're just watching this story
unfold and it just is perfectly paired
with the music good well done you'll
finally understand why that one guy is
always dressed in white facepaint every
Halloween again another check mark um on
things that I finally understand because
of Tara's never seen it all right I
never saw the movie but I predict you
will whip your hair I will say even
people who haven't seen every movie ever
can enjoy things guys see paint your
face will look like air dragon for the
video please I would never thanks for
recommending this you guys I really want
to do movies that y'all want to see me
do I am having a harder time finding
big-name movies which is exciting to me
because it means that I've seen actual
film no but I still have a couple I saw
the scene The Godfather is no end in
sight here let me know what you want me
to do though I really love seeing in the
comments I don't read the comments of
the life but I really love doing on my
Twitter so what you guys want to see me
see thank you for watching and I'll see
y'all next week
[Music]
[Applause]